but he's with us in bloomington illinois
to start off this hour hey buddy how are
you
i'm good thanks for taking my call sure
man what's up
oh um well my wife and i we are on baby
step two
uh i've actually just really gotten
going um we've
paid off about eight grand since march
good for you um
and we're probably looking around at our
interest rates right now and
we've had our house for about five or
six years and we've got a 30-year fixed
about 4.375 i believe um
wondering if it's a good idea to pause
for just a minute to be able to cash
flow
a 15-year refinance for you know to pay
for our closing costs
what do you owe on the house oh about 96
000. you don't have enough equity to
just roll your closing costs into the
deal
i'm sure that we could i said it would
be a good idea to you know
be smart be smarter than stopping your
debt snowball
okay all right and you think it would be
a good idea to
go ahead and refinance while we're on
baby step two
yeah it's the only thing it does is it
decreases your monthly cash flow
i mean your payment even by going from a
30 to a 15 even though you're dropping
two percent is gonna go up right chris
oh without a shadow of a doubt so in
looking at that you do want to make sure
that you're
never refinancing just to refinance i
mean you've got to make sure that you're
having some kind of savings and some
kind of rate
change there have you gotten a quote
buddy on what a payment would be on a 15
yeah um we're about we're having about
another hundred dollars in payments
um um that's you know another part of
the issues
yeah it's only 100 more dollars but
we've also got about 120
000 in debt right now yeah well the
hundred dollars is not going to kill you
and it's a good move to do while these
rates are down um
and so yeah go ahead and take it to a 15
and go ahead and get that two percent or
whatever rate they're quoting you right
now which is a
you know you're saving two to three
percent right now uh it's definitely the
time to do it
and uh but i wouldn't i wouldn't hit the
cash flow
you get the the closing costs out of
pockets you can throw at that 120 000 in
debt
and just roll it up into the mortgage
you're still gonna recoup
either way it doesn't change your recoup
your recoup is you know about two
thousand dollars a year
about two percent on a hundred thousand
dollar loan approximately so
you're going to come out pretty quick is
there a scenario where you would have
someone pause
baby step two just to refinance
ah i'm sitting here trying to think and
i can't think of it
i um most of the time when you're doing
refinance you have room to roll your
closing costs
so it doesn't come up very often if that
were the case that would mean they had
almost no equity
right which would give me pause on other
things
and cause me to go have you got too much
house what's going on here
heloc uh you know what's happening that
where'd all your equity go
and uh i want to learn some more about
it then because that would be a fairly
unusual
yes it was scenario so you're right it's
a good question to think through
but most of the time we roll it on in
because either way you're going to pay
the money
you're either going to pay it when you
pay off the mortgage or you're going to
pay it when you
uh yeah out of your pocket right now
while you're trying to pay off the 120
000
so it pays me now pays me later you know
you don't get it either way
so that's the thing i i it sounds like
i'm telling you to borrow money
but i'm really not because it's rolled
in there and you're gonna you're gonna
you know your payment is gonna go you're
getting rid of 15 years of payments
that's right
while you're at it so it just makes a
ton of sense all you out there doing
house shopping remember number one
you want to make sure that you're out of
debt you've got a fully funded emergency
fund and you've saved for a down payment
i know rates are low right now and
people are getting house fever dave
people are twitching they're like hogan
you understand the rates are so low
you're not going
to shower helps yeah it doesn't matter
what the rates are doing don't let the
rates determine your plan
you walk the process and look at it and
be clear on that and also one more tip
hogan's tips today a heloc is a mortgage
people
okay a home equity line of credit it's a
big credit card attached to your house
that's using your equity okay it's the
most creative thing the banking
industry's done in the last 30 years
but it is a mortgage because there's a
deed recorded on your property
so if you have a heloc you have a second
mortgage yeah it is
any mortgage that's after the first
mortgage is the second one
and the one after that's called a third
one and that's where the name comes from
right yeah sorry it's just yeah you
still got your butt a mortgage you
really did and
and uh they'll still take your house if
you don't pay it it's called a
foreclosure
in either case so you will learn these
things the hard way like i did or you
will learn them the right way and not do
them
like mr hogan is suggesting